حيث نقلت وكاله روتورز عن وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه قولها ان طائره عسكريه امريكيه
حلقت فوق مضيقت تايوان وقالت الوكاله ان
طائره الامريكيه وهي من طراز ب 8 اي
بوسيدون عبرت المضيق من الشمال الى الجنوب
دون اعطاء مزيدا من التفاصيل
ومن جهته قال الجيش الصيني انه راقب طائره
الامريكيه عن كثب وهي تحلق فوق مضيق
التايوان صباح اليوم واضاف الجيش الصيني
ان تحليق طائره عسكريه امريكيه فوق مضيق
تايوان يهدد الامن والاستقرار في مضيق
تايوان واشددت المؤسسه العسكريه الصينيه
على رفضها هذا العمل الامريكي
ومن ناحيته قال سفير الولايات المتحده في
الصين نيكولاس بيرز قال ان لدى الولايات
المتحده
مسؤوليه الحفاظ على قوتها العسكريه في
تايوان ومحيطها للتاكد من ان لدى تايوان
القدره على ردع اي نوع من الاعمال
الهجوميه الصينيه واضاف برز ان وضع
الولايات المتحده في منطقتي الهادئ
والهندي اقوى مما كان عليه قبل خمس او عشر
سنوات وان الصين تدرك ان الامريكيين باقون
في المنطقه
وينضم الينا من واشنطن مراسل الجزيره ناصر
الحسين اهلا بك ناصر
يعني ما هي ملابسات عمليه تحقيق طائره
عسكريه فوق مضيق تايوان ما المعلومات
المتوفره حول هذا الامر
حقيقه الامر ان الولايات المتحده
والبرتغون حتى هذه اللحظه ونحن نتحدث حتى
بعد مرور عده ساعات الان من حادث الطائره
الامريكيه التي جابت الاجواء بكل اريحيها
هناك في منطقه المضيق في تايوان الحقيقه
ان يرفض ان يتحدث حتى الان او اي مصادر
امريكيه ان تعطيك ولو تعليقا بسيطا لكن
بوضوح يمكن الان قراءه هذا الموقف
الامريكي الذي لنقل انه يعطي الان الساعه
بالساعه بعد حوادث المنطاد الصيني الذي
خلق حاله من الاستياء والغضب العارب هنا
في الولايات المتحده باعتبار ان الصين
تجرات على اقتحام السماء الامريكيه
والتجسس ولو عن بعد ولو ان ذلك معروف الى
حد ما في الاوساط الاستخباراتيه الان
الولايات المتحده يبدو انها بدات بالفعل
تفعل ما تقول
والكثيرون سيرون في الطائره الامريكيه
التي حلقت بهدوء وباريحيه فوق السماء
تايوان المضيق في تايوان دون ان تتمكن
الصين او تريد الصين ان تقوم باي رد فعل
رد فعل عسكري سيرارنا في ذلك تحديا
يشبه تحدي الصيني عبر استخدام المنطادات
وبالتالي القراءه العسكريه الان ان
الولايات المتحده تؤكد من خلال هذا
الطيران الذي تحدث دون مشاكل تذكر هذه
المره تؤكد انها باقيه في المنطقه عسكريا
ولاحظوا معي تلك التصريحات للسفير
الامريكي تقريبا مباشره بعد ان اكتشف
المصريون تلك الصينيون تلك الطائره
الامريكيه في تصريحات لنقل جديده ذات نفحه
الدبلوماسيه هجوميه اكثر من اي وقت مضى
يقول سفر الامريكي في تلك الصريحات هنا في
واشنطن السفير الصيني اقول السفير
الامريكي لدى الصين هنا في واشنطن يقول ان
موقع الولايات المتحده في منطقه الصين في
منطقه المحيط الهادي اقوى من اي وقت مضى
ويقارنه بالسنوات الماضيه وهو باطلاق
الحال يقصد الموقع العسكري الاستراتيجي
الذي تحتله الولايات المتحده هناك كبقعه
في تايوان تنطلق منها لمراقبه الصين
ومحاوله
اقناعها بعدم التحرك الامريكيون يدركون
الى اي حد منطقه تايوان حيويه استراتيجيا
للصين لكن لا موقفهم ان منطقه تايوان يجب
ان تظل تحت المظله الغربيه تحت المظله
الامريكيه وهذه التصريحات الجديده للسفير
الامريكي بالصين تمشي وتتجه في هذا
الاتجاه اتجاه التحدي لنقل واتجاه اعاده
تكريس وتذكير المنطقه بان القوات
الامريكيه العسكريه موجوده هناك وان القوه
الامريكيه الاستراتيجيه باقتصادها
وشركاتها وكافه كل الثقافه الامريكيه لنقل
موجوده في الصين وفي منطقه جنوب الصين في
منطقه تايوان لتبقى وتظل وفي هذه
التصريحات رد مباشر على تلك التصريحات في
وقت سابق للقوى العسكري للقوه العسكريه
الصينيه والرئاسه والسياسيين الصينيين
الذين اعتبروا حدث الطائره الامريكيه حدثا
اغضبهم بطبيعه حال ويجب الرد عليه شكرا
جزيلا لك ناصر الحسيني كنت معنا من اول
شمس